so a major wrench is perhaps about to be
thrown into President Biden's
re-election run because they've tried to
make this guy go away but he just isn't
Robert F Kennedy Jr is now expected to
announce that he will run likely as an
independent that's what it looks like
this announcement will be instead of
trying to OU Biden as a democrat in the
party that he has spent his whole life
in and obviously generations of his
family so it could be a move that
changes the game for 2024 RFK Jr
consistently pulled in double digits
among Democrat primary voters watch
this I want to tell you now what I've
come to understand after 6 months of
campaigning there is a path to Victory
it's not through playing the game by the
corrupt rules that the corrupt powers
and the vested interests have rigged to
keep us all in their th join me in
Philadelphia on October 9th there I'll
share with you our path to the White
House and how we can all participate in
healing our nation interesting
interesting music underneath that the
whole thing is interesting RFK Jr uh
could play spoiler or he could do better
than that if uh it works out his way the
top concerns about Biden of course
continue to be his Advanced age and
liberal comedian Bill Maher thinks that
it's time for Biden to drop out watch
what he said someone has to convince
President Biden that if he runs again
he's going to turn the country back over
to Trump and
go go down in history as Ruth Bader
Biden the person who doesn't know when
to quit and so does great damage to
their party and their
country very interesting Jesse let me
start with you what is the impact of RFK
Jr getting in and the word is that he's
going to run as an
independent it hurts Biden more than it
hurts Trump I looked at some video for
the RFK
rallies you will not see Trump looking
voters in RFK rallies it is college
students and black
Americans okay that's not what I'd
consider the Trump base okay how about
this how about at least you're admitting
now that black people don't like Donald
Trump I'm talking demographically
Jessica or did that go over your head
black is a Democrat how about this okay
it trust me they don't vote for Trump
they vote for Democrats I thought they
voted for Trump in bigger numbers than
any prior
candidate he keeps banking on the fact
that he's getting more and more black
Trump is not winning the black vote
he'll do better than last time but when
you see a crowd of black people with a
crowd of college students you do not say
that is a trump rally I mean come on
people are we stupid here come on we D
all Bowman here what's going on all
right also let's just say New Hampshire
critical vote electorally okay you see
Trump's name you see Biden's name and
you see Kennedy Kennedy is synonymous
with Democrat everybody in New Hampshire
used to live in Massachusetts they're
all Boston transplants he this guy has
Boston coming out of his pores who has a
firmer grip on their base Joe Biden or
Donald Trump Donald Trump does Donald
Trump absolutely does have you ever met
a trump voter that's like you know what
I'm really considering voting for
Kennedy an environmental lawyer actually
who if you go on his website wants to
stop mining logging and oil exploration
if you go on his website RFK Jr who I
like also wants government run daycare
okay this he is
pro-choice if I'm not saying Trump
people wouldn't consider voting for I'm
saying overwhelmingly they this pulls
from Biden okay well let's talk about
this so he says that he want and I know
you you've interviewed him he talks
about being the first podcast president
he has a lot of support among Rogan
listeners among Jordan Peterson
listeners and what he's talking about in
this video is is that there has to be a
different path
elect or support all I'm saying is that
he has a lot of people young people very
interested in what he's talking about
now some of them may think he's
conservative and when they actually dig
deeper and scratch below the surface
they may decide he's not for them but he
is getting a lot of attention because
he's sort of you know cut from a
different clo he's also making a big
deal out of the his family doesn't like
him they don't support him at all I
definitely Democrat definitely Democrats
probably win M he wouldn't even do well
in Massachusetts in in that case you
know where everybody is supposed to
kenned don't do well in Massachusetts
Mara he won't do well can I tell you
something I was at a parade in
Massachusetts on the 4th of July the
Kennedy bus went by and everyone was
like this they don't want that Kennedy
they want the other Kennedy they were
worried about his driving they want Jack
Kennedy they want his father they are
not necessarily subscribing all right
let me get you in here Janan because I
want to hear your thoughts on this I
think that he will pull some I think he
will pull some votes from Republicans
now whether or not it would be
significant I don't know some well I
think he will pull votes from
Republicans I really do but I don't
think it's significant at all I really
don't I I have to tell you I think I
think the interesting thing is that he's
made a decision he's not going anywhere
in the Democrat Party well you're not
going anywhere in the Independent party
either and you know what I think I think
he believes and this is what I believe
and I I I'm sure there's no basis for it
I don't think Joe Biden is ultimately
going to be the candidate that could be
wrong wrong but I think he knows that
he's not going to be the candidate if
Joe Biden isn't he's got nowhere else to
go nobody else wants him he's put all
this energy in so he's going to make a
big announcement on October 9th is not
going to make a damn bit of difference
to anybody well the the race is very
tight 60% say they don't want Trump to
run 70% say they don't want Biden to run
there are a lot of people out there who
are looking for someone else he's doing
backflips off of uh rocks and doing
push-ups and proving like by the way I
am actually younger and healthier than
either one of these guys I I disagree
with judge I think this is a true
independent he will pull from Democrats
and he will pull from Republicans he
will pull from Republicans primarily
from the vax positions that he's taken
uh the voui he's been outspoken on that
and and it and it's you know I talk I
talk to people who like him I actually
like him and I think sometimes he goes
over the top the Dems screwed him and
they chose Biden who was this broken
down incoherent mess over RFK Jr and
said they forced him out he's sharp he's
well read he's curious he's open-minded
uh why would they do that why would they
choose an incoherent mess over somebody
who's got his his head together that's
the reason you can control this hollowed
out husk but you can't control a free
thinker and there's something that RFK
Jr has in common with Trump they're both
dangerous because they're both outside
they both grew up in the world right
they grew up in the world of power but
they're outside and they're qu they're
both questioning exactly what is going
on inside these worlds that makes them
dangerous so they're targeted uh RFK was
targeted by the Democratic party you
look at Joe Rogan being targeted you
look at musk being sued by the
government you see what's happening to
Trump you look at Russell Brand you look
what happened to Tucker do you notice a
trend here the people that are outside
are the ones that are being taken off
the chessboard I think that's pretty
interesting you look at you look at Joe
Biden right now we were looking trying
to look for some tape from him from six
months ago and we found it that the
Cline in just 6 months is frightening
it's pronounced this guy is on a
downward slide and I think you're right
I don't think he's going to be the
nominee and that means RFK Jr might
might Loom a little bit bigger than we
think but I don't think he will ever be
accepted by democrats because of the vax
position because of you know I mean
Kennedy is his last name but he doesn't
line up with Kennedy's on anything no
and they're Caroline Kennedy and her son
were doing an interview about it and we
asked by Savannah Guthrie you know why
do you stand by because uh Jack
schosberg her son posted a video and
they said yeah absolutely this is this
is not a Democrat and we're it didn't go
so far to say we're Biden Democrats
because they're Kennedy but they are so
the person who knows best of all who
he's going to pull votes from is RFK Jr
himself and he admitted it so he was on
a podcast because that's where he hangs
out with a a comedian named Theo vau and
he said yeah he's sitting back you know
he's in like a tight gray t-shirt like
looking good and he's like yeah I pull
from Trump and you know why his approval
rating with Democrats is negative 31 in
the New York Times Sia pole and guess
what he is with the Republicans plus 28
well then why is he at 16% in the
Democrat I think well first of all I
would repo the whole thing now it's a
few months later but I do think that
there're that was a bit of 16% with
Democrats Jessica that's a lot it's
higher than most Republicans against TR
can I just say that there is there's a
difference if he's running within the
Democratic party name right for that
party for our party's nomination and
someone wants to express an anti-biden
vote then they're going to go with the
other Democrat but if he is not a
Democrat and voting for him means that
you're going to elect Donald Trump so
the never trumpers are going to vote for
Kennedy is that what you're saying no I
don't think really are you I'm saying
that there are Trump voters who like his
antix stuff they love that he's an
outside isn't an issue anymore he's not
to the right of trump on any issue you
have been so utterly incoherent in this
block I can't follow I'm so coherent I'm
incoherent to
you all right coming up ahead have
YouTube pranks gone too far an
influencer gets shot after harassing a
man for clicks wait till you see this
and think about what you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else